londres le maire sortant ken livingstone
longtemps surnommé ken ou rouge pour ses
sympathies marxiste précédente se
présente pour un troisième mandat mais
il pourrait être menacée par un nouveau
venu le candidat conservateur boris
johnson ancien journaliste 43 ans
au programme et à l'esprit très
britannique maryse burgot et le rang des
bois boris johnson célèbre pour sa mèche
rebelle et son sens de l'humour que vous
allez lui aussi grâce à votre humour
tellement anglais
j'espère d'être élu lundi éternel
sourire en coin le candidat conservateur
à la mairie de londres fait
habituellement le pitre mais en cette
veille d'élection celui qu'on appelle le
clown de la droite britannique se
prendrait presque au sérieux tous
français pensaient alors il faut côté
hip hop johnson demain il fait campagne
dans un route masters tout un symbole
il veut remettre en circuit ces fameux
bus à étage avec plateforme arrière
supprimé par le maire actuel
boris johnson très connu pour ses
allures homophones et c'est le bon mot a
donc un programme améliorer les
transports et ne pas étendre la très
impopulaire taxe d'embouteillage
les londoniens vont t'ils demain
majoritairement voté pour cet
excentrique ex journaliste mais
tellement menti que ken livingstone le
maire travailliste sortant se fait du
souci malgré un bilan assez positif
le candidat qui l'emportera demain soir
occupera cet immeuble si particulier
celui de la mairie de londres première
capitale européenne et budget colossal
13 milliards d'euros
[Musique]